voilà c'était en français moi c'est donc
l'invitée des cinq dernières minutes et
c'est un mythe et c'est sara forestier
bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
rejoint ici sur ce plateau vous avez
envie qu'elle ne peut lourd un peu
changé avec la cérémonie avec ce très
beau couple vous l'aviez apporter tout à
l'heure il est plein il est resté là bas
ce plateau ce très beau césar du
meilleur espoir féminin pour le votre
rôle de lydia dans l' esquive le film
d'abdellatif kechiche lui aussi consacré
un meilleur réalisateur meilleur film ça
baigne pour vous c'est quand même un
week-end d'enfer aux chemins paraît
alors on va voir d'abord comment vous
avez reçus pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
suivi à la télé comment vous avez reçu
ce fameux césar on regarde ça en images
le meilleur espoir féminin est attribué
à sara forestier
je sors c'est une reconnaissance de tout
notre travail à tous à toutes les
personnes qui ont travaillé sur ce film
est contente
c'est génial voilà vous étiez content tu
voulais toujours ça fait de recevoir ce
genre de prix
vous massez sermoner vraiment pour moi
c'est un honneur surtout avec ce film
leskiw je suis vraiment très très fier
et recevoir déjà un césar c'est un
honneur mais avec ce film pour ce film
je suis très très fiable comme s'il ya
conduit à ça pas du tout alors jeu pour
gagner
non non pas du tout je savais pas du
tout que j'étais là et je je parte je
suis venu en me disant rouge je pense
pas que c'est moi qui vais la voir
j'étais vraiment étonné alors mai mais
vraiment j'étais fier de le recevoir
surtout pour ce film et tout le monde a
souligné vise évidemment que c'est un
petit film entre guillemets qui a
emporté le budget vous mais tous les
autres prix dont on a parlé et c'est par
rapport à des grosses machines eu les
choristes on en parlait très terrain
c'est une petite revanche de votre part
c'est pour ça que c'est si important que
ça non parce que j'ai jugé pas de
revanche à avoir parce que moi - immo
est un fait les griffes du tout mais non
je suis très fier c'est pas parce que
parce qu'on a galéré oui mais c'est
surtout parce qu'on s'est battus pour
quelque chose on est on est très fiers
de ce film parce qu'on sait on ya
vraiment cru lui seul le travail et j'ai
lu ça quelque part c'est un film de
troupes au sein d'équipés derrière on a
fait deux mois de répétitions on a
travaillé comme au théâtre et c'est et
c'est pour ça que je suis fier parce que
je et puis je je trouve qu'à modèle est
extrêmement talentueux donc je suis très
fier de recevoir ce césar avec me qui
m'a dirigé dans ce film alors on regarde
d'autres extraits ce faux si c'est un
extrait du film lui-même et de vous dans
ce film les skis
je voudrais bien pouvoir baisser petit
hall elle éclaire sur moi vous savez sur
votre bouche avec la même ouais ben
c'est pareil
quoi c'est pareil c'est pas pareil de
tanger marque sur votre chat mais n'est
pas l'envié et exceller madame ne
voilà-t-il pas et mamie revenait dans un
quart d'heure ah les femmes de chambre
de mon pays ne trouve pas qu'on ne les
appelle monsieur il faut que je parte à
madrid en a franchement la vérité tout
compris date en fait trop je fais
trotter masnièrois la saint trond s'est
vu lui qui nous a sorti ça j'essaie moi
franchement un chez moi ça fait trop
voilà ça fait trop je trouve ça mais sur
le vote comme un fétu battu le cast de
cuivre ça c'est pas dans la zone arrive
au départ
pas vraiment
c'est quoi cette histoire c'est des
jeunes comme ça de banlieue un qui s'en
sortent entre guillemets ou qui trouve
autre chose
à travers cette pièce de marivaux merci
avec cd cd moi ce que j'aime dans le
regard d'abdel est ce que montre ce film
c'est que les jeunes de bonus et des
êtres humains et ils ont un potentiel
artistique comme malheureusement parfois
y'a pas les structures pour mettre en
valeur ou faire exprès film sur la
banlieue ou non positif simplement mais
parce que l'on banlieue ça reste une
banlieue mais il ya des êtres humains de
dans les barres de béton sur des barres
de béton mais les instruments c'est les
êtres humains il ya un potentiel si vous
n'êtes pas de la banlieue vous moi je
sais pas du tout de la banlieue comme on
prépare un film comme ça et n'ont qu'un
rôle comme ça mais en travaillant
beaucoup
et d'ailleurs je vais vous dire parce
que je viens d'avoir un coup de fil
d'abdel les réalisateurs via lequel
chiche qui vient de me dire que le film
sort en salles mercredi à parce que je
veux être honnête avec vous je sais de
le voir hier sur deux est pauvre budget
pas réussi parce que je viens
d'apprendre qu'à une ressortie du film
300 spectateurs la première fois là avec
ce cr ça devrait aller beaucoup mieux
yalla yalla et elle est là et l'action
commune de trail l'accent votre
personnage cetera la banlieue vous êtes
vous êtes allez vous immerger en
banlieue mais déjà je pense que déjà de
nos jours ce langage est pas du tout et
on peut pas être trop jeune en langage
oui voilà le langage des katas vieux qui
voudraient est étranger à ça y'a pas toi
tu es obligé d'associer voilà et nous
produire du mois j'avais encore il faut
travailler il faut battre
et on a fait deux mois de répétitions et
on a vraiment travaillé quoi tout petit
bout cela qu'on s'habitue à vous voir
j'ai l'impression vous sortez vous êtes
un fil à la patte ça va sortir ses
sorties ses tournées sa nouvelle tournée
avec emmanuelle béart charles berling et
cetera ça vous fait quoi de travail et
des grands prix mais comme ça pas moi
déjà ce qui m'intéresse chez les gens
c'est les personnels même pas voler tard
parce que même pour eux ça serai pas
oublier l'homme où la femme est bien sûr
pourquoi je vous parle à vous c'est vous
qui m'intéressait jeudi dominique blanc
et ce qui m'intéresse c'est leur travail
et moi dominique blanc je vous dis
sincèrement elle m'a impressionné sur le
tournage c'est ça qui m'intéresse
en tout cas il faut qu'on aille voir
leskiw à partir de mercredi à jeudi marc
savard sortir merci beaucoup avec venu
c'est la face c'est la fin de ce journal
tout de suite la météo valérie alexandre
avec la neige carole gaessler 7 à 20
heures va troquer 22h45 mais sur
complément d'enquêté ne pas manquer et
on se retrouve demain à 13h bonne après
midi sur france 2